for the first time in a couple of years
lake mead mojave adventures is
announcing the return of its colorado
river rafting tours this spring jillian
had the chance to experience the tour
check this out
you can experience the hoover dam like
never before through the lake mead
mojave adventures the day trip
experience begins at the lake mead rv
village where you are greeted by a tour
guide as you get ready for your journey
so to the left is lake leed lake mead is
the largest man-made reservoir in the
united states from interesting facts to
a level one security hidden path there
is a lot to experience just on the drive
to the raft so right now you are looking
at the mike o'callaghan and pat tillman
memorial bridge and from that bridge
down to the surface of the hoover dam is
almost a thousand feet and we're right
in the middle of it i am so excited
we're about to jump on a raft and go on
a hoover dam rafting adventure let's go
see what it's all about this is part of
the
black canyon national water trail so
this trip will start here at the base of
hoover dam and then we'll travel 11
miles south to willow beach and we're
going to get a chance to see red tail
hawks great blue heron
bighorn sheep ospreys if we have a good
rain we have a lot of flowers floor and
fauna we'll see some splotches of yellow
out here which is called brittle bush
there's some still some historical sites
that we can you know get close to and
then point out
and as we were driving in here we're
trying to take pictures and video and i
feel like it doesn't do it of justice
you have to be in here to really see it
and take in the beauty what would you
say to people who maybe our locals don't
know this exists or how would you get
them to come out here well you have
these stunning views the general public
is not allowed where we're at so we have
access to this spectacular view of
hoover dam everybody else is looking up
on top trying to take a picture
and we have the ability to
you're on a raft kind of looking up from
here you see the dam and it's really in
its glory so what we started with about
30 almost 40 years ago is what we call a
regular run starts here at the base of
hoover dam travels 11 miles down to
willow beach it's a one-way smooth water
fully narrated motor assisted raft trip
and for adults it's 140 and for kids
it's 110. so
kids are five to fifteen so kids four
and under are free if you're a little
short on time
then we we created what's called a
postcard tour which gives you a snapshot
of hoover dam and you start here again
and we
go up about a mile and a half down river
it's fully narrated again it's about an
hour and a half and it starts and ends
here there are several different tours
you can embark on all showing you
close-up views of what the colorado
river has to offer and the guys that
took measurements did so manually up
above and a little bit to the right you
can see an old hand crank well i'm
really sad it's over but that's a wrap
thank you to kathleen for being the best
tour guide you guys have to check this
out it's the best day ever and i got a
good tan while i was out here see you
guys later
to book a tour you can visit